love this guy love when he calls in love
his show to walk in dead aaron sundays
at nine eastern on amc with new episodes
being released one week early on amc
plus the series final epis eight
episodes are gonna air later on this
year currently airing part two of three
within the epic final extended season
and amc just greenlit a new series
starring this man checking out
the uh popular maggie and negan
characters in a post-apocalyptic
manhattan meaning they're in madison
square garden in 2022
joining us here on the rich eisen show a
man who feels like he took lucille to
the nards because his seahawks just
traded away
russell wilson and cut
bobby wagner the great jeffrey dean
morgan how's that for a setup how's that
for a wind-up sir how about that
yeah that was that was golden it's so
golden that i almost will try to use
better language than is on the tip of my
tongue well that was
great
so well you're the one you're the one
did you let's just start with the most
important thing did you in fact
take glenn watts or nuts as your fantasy
team name after your last conversation
glenn what's her nuts uh
kicked ass by the way and yeah with my
name all season long i
probably won the regular season
um
against like all my crew and then was
not aware that the playoffs started like
two games before the end of the season
right and then my whole roster got
knocked out by kobe
and i loved the playoffs after taking
everyone's ass
hmm
such as the vagaries of fantasy football
sir
stood proud for a long time
and then failed
by the way that sentence in itself that
sex in itself is fantastic glenn what's
her nuts uh stuck around for a long time
but then failed that's amazing um i'm
proud that we actually
provided that to you keeping the damn
name by the way that's gonna be the
whole deal going forward in fantasy
football all right jeffrey dean morgan i
know you were pissed i saw you on
twitter the day that uh russell wilson
got traded and then
later on that night bobby wagner getting
cut those are those are two uh very
difficult blows for seahawks fans like
yourself
just say that sentence again bobby
wagoner getting cut
i know what the hell is that about
um yeah i was uh and still
am
steaming about the whole thing um
you know i uh i spent the day the other
day looking at this lock kid seeing what
he can do um
because some article came out i think on
espn this guy was like well
seahawks are looking at him as a
not a not a backup but as a starter
and no
no that's not going to work
at all unless we're just going to
completely go into rebuild and and i
can't imagine
pete going into rebuild at you know the
ripe age of whatever he is
70.
yeah yeah
that
um but yeah i'm i'm angry i'm not happy
i think cutting bobby was you know it
kind of kind of felt like russell could
you know he's been squeaking for a
couple years um
and so i kind of could see that coming
but the bobby thing
that kind of tore me a new one and and
then you know there's there's rumors of
you know uh locket being on the block
and maybe dk and a couple other players
i mean
some real stupid stuff that i can't
figure out unless we're just going to go
relive the 90s and i really don't want
to relive the 90s again well i mean
look i i i
don't think they're going to ditch lock
it that would be crazy you know and and
dk
and then there is a possibility that
seattle could be in on you know desean
watson should be
you know you know
he was not criminally charged in what
what's been hanging over him for a year
um he is potentially 22 uh yeah 22 cases
hanging over him that he wasn't
criminally charged in but
you know i mean look i
i don't know where i stand on this but i
mean the dude can play football um
i know the two offers have gone in on
him already with uh with the saints and
somebody else
um
and we'll see we'll see i think that's
going to be very telling
about what the future holds if the
seahawks go after them i mean they might
as well use all that stuff they got from
denver to go after a player um
because we have not been good at draft
uh since i don't know 2012 was the last
successful draft we've had with picks
um
so i'm not holding my breath for that at
all and it's a year for quarterbacks so
we find ourselves in kind of a rough
position it's either
it's either rebuild or
um
or we make a move and the the watson
move is kind of the only move that i can
see to be made right now
uh if you're gonna not waste the career
of tyler lockett d.k metcalf jeffrey
dean morgan you're a damn shame
jeffrey dean morgan here from the
walking dead um on the rich eisen show
art so let me just get right to it here
in the same way that brady you know
brady in tampa
patriots fans even found themselves
rooting for him there and they're like
okay that's another it's another
conference so i can root i can root for
tom there are you going to become a
bronco fan now a little bit
jeffrey i don't know i i you know that's
a that's a stretch it's a stretch i mean
oh god you know i i find myself maybe
rooting more for wherever bobby goes
unless he goes to the cowboys
[Music]
why is that a bridge too far jeffrey why
is that a bridge too far why would that
be a bridge too far
and i actually told bobby i said look
man wherever you go i am i am going to
pull for you in the cowboys and then all
bets are off um
and as far as ross said denver
look i mean i see what they got i am and
i think that russell is the missing
piece he went to a hell of a division
um i think you know the three four best
quarterbacks of the best five
quarterbacks are in that division now
um so it's not going to be easy but um
they certainly have a shot and if it's
denver versus anybody in the nfc i'm
going to root for denver
um
[Music]
because i can't root for nac teams
because i'm a seahawk guy
yeah
so you spoke to bobby it just killed me
it just killed me
and i still have that in my mind so you
know i still can look at all those
denver fans and say haha
so i i whatever you know he
he kind of left on his own accord it's
tough to it's really tough because you
know he had issues he had issues in
seattle and he made him known
so i don't know how much of a surprise
that came but
you know we need a quarterback
that's crazy i'm more stuck on the
seahawk open all than the russell in
denver of it all i i've sort of just
come to terms with that part of it
so do you say you spoke to bobby wagner
you connected with him since he got
caught did you say that we
tweet got it
we uh we tweeted at each other um
okay it's been pretty quiet man uh i
know a couple of reporters in seattle
that called them the day of the trade
and
are the trade the drop right and uh
he didn't want to talk he didn't want to
even like talk to him he was upset and
uh
and that upsets me i think that that
made me more mad than the russell thing
i guess i i like by far a lot more it
was just kind of so disrespectful and
the fact that they didn't call them
you know you want your team to uh
have some class you know we look at some
of these organizations and they don't
have any class at all and i had better
high higher expectations of john and
pete i really did and
to hear that they didn't even have the
balls to call him and let him know what
they were going to do it's it's pretty
disappointing yeah i know he said i
didn't even hear it from them that i
wasn't coming back and that is that is
you know
but but there are other teams that
wouldn't even even cut them until
everybody filled up their their slots
that's true you know look they did they
gave him an opportunity to kind of and
he's his own agent too so he he's look
he's gonna be fine but you know he was a
big just like russell was they were both
such big parts of that community
um in seattle and kind of meant so much
to so many people
um
including me obviously um
that it's just it's a tough pill to
swallow you just want more i think from
the teams you root for i certainly do um
but i know it's a business i mean hell
they we all we all are
locked into some business somewhere and
it's it's ruthless in in all of it i
guess
jeffrey dean morgan here on the rich
housing church
well i have a feeling jeffrey that if i
had spoken to you thursday night uh we
would have had to have had a mute button
um a lot of earmuffs for children on
peacock right now it would have been a
complete bleep
i really have been trying to like you
know meditate and breathe going into
this thing today um but you've been like
talking to you now yeah i can i feel my
blood pressure i can't hear it
i could hear it i could hear it um i i
know that you said and i appreciate you
swapping out the f word for the h word
earlier on in this conversation all of
us were ready to oh my god save your
content good okay
and my high school basketball coach
is a big fan of your show and i i know
he's listening how nice oh god
calm it down
i love that um so let's get into um the
finale here of the final eight episodes
of the walking dead later on this year
um
what what what can you tell people what
can they actually give me something that
i know that might
you know those orders basically not to
say anything of course and continue to
talk about it which is always a joy
um we are shooting the final episode
uh as we speak really i'm in the middle
of the shooting that the final episode
ever of the walking dead is being filmed
right now how emotional is that on your
side i think that we are
how emotional is that on your set right
a lot but i got to tell you man after
we've been here for 17 months 18 months
um
it's time to go you know what i mean
like
i think that it would have been if it
was a regular season and we were only
shooting you know 16 episodes we did 30
this year um damn
and we were only here for six months and
not 18. it would be a lot
there'd be a lot more emotion at this
point everybody's just like ready to be
done um ready to go home
where are you for those who may not know
where are you in atlanta as far as what
we're airing i think
pardon me where are you
you're in georgia okay right uh we're in
a little town called sonoya
which is you know an hour
south
west of of atlanta okay
so you're ready to go
um
i miss my family uh and it's my little
boy's birthday today happy birthday gus
uh and you know i've missed enough
birthdays and holidays in the last 18
months but that being said i think the
show is going to be super cool um
i i hope that it comes to an ending that
uh everyone will be happy with and and
now we've announced that uh you know
they're we're going to do a spin-off so
i guess we don't need to die
um
[Laughter]
sorry yeah i'm still not sure why we
announced that already it was sort of a
shocker to me
um
but yeah and we're gonna shoot in
manhattan so uh i get to be home which
would be super cool and i i think seeing
zombies in manhattan is gonna be
uh
kind of super fantastic well i mean we
already see the 2021 2022 new york
knicks so we're already there jeffrey so
um so
so i mean you got the giants the knicks
yeah i could have i could have well i
know you're in manhattan
i know i could have gone jets i could
have gone giants i could have gone in
any of those directions so um yeah so
you know you know actually uh where our
studio is is
right next to the metal lamp so um
so we've got a studio in in the jersey
side and then we'll shoot in the city oh
i'll get a little bit a little bit
everything all the flavors
so okay so uh the new uh show on the
isle of the dead you'll be doing it uh
lauren cohen as well and uh and jimmy
hoffa clearly right we'll get up
negan and maggie okay we got jimmy hoffa
involved in there too we'll get that
because he's out there in the middle
of an episode yeah he's going to be
chasing me down to heaven
i can't wait wow that's pretty cool so
so you're shooting it right now that is
amazing and so you obviously know how
this is ending or
of the walking dead the mothership right
correct the mothership show so are they
giving you like alternate scripts and
stuff like that or you know exactly what
it is and you're you're shooting like
yeah i mean
we had so many issues just trying to get
the right script um
the actors are confused at this point um
but yeah there's there's a little bit of
hoodwinkery going on um i think i just
made up a word by the way you keep that
one um
so yeah i mean there's always like a
veil of secrecy um it's not as crazy as
it was
you know five years ago with like fans
trying to figure out what was going on
but it's it's there's a certain
kind of craziness with this last season
and especially this this last bit of the
last season um
it's been a little bit nutty again um
but you know we're close we're close and
i think you i think the fans are going
to be happy and uh
we'll see just trying to survive it all
man well jeffrey um have a good have a
good uh time finishing that up and then
getting home to your fam
um you know uh happy birthday to your
son shout out to your uh high school
coach
um and uh porn and then porn went out
for the legion of boom era right now for
your brother dude more one out for the
ladies boom
oh
god
i've done so good in this interview
though i'm very proud of myself well
done hardly any earmuffs required
jeffrey dean morgan
well done have a great time now shooting
the rest of your show everybody i super
appreciate it anytime you know anytime
you're here i just you know uh love to
have you back you've been here once i
think and anytime you want to come back
you know we're here for you uh you know
hopefully uh maybe we can come back for
the new show i'm gonna start shooting
that you know pretty soon um and uh i
would love to love to come and see you
fantastic same to you you take care of
jeffrey dean morgan thanks for the time
all right brother i appreciate it right
back at you at jd morgan on twitter i
follow him you should as well almost a
million people do you're missing out if
you don't
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here